in this video we'd like to introduce how
to use Google Cloud AI tools to quickly
bring the power of large language models
to Enterprise systems
many people are now starting to think
about how to bring gen Ai and llms to
Production Services and facing with
several challenges
you may be wondering how to integrate
llms or AI chat Bots with existing it
systems databases and business data
we have thousands of products
how can I let llm memorize them all
precisely
or how to handle the hallucination
issues in AI chatbots to build a
reliable service
here is a quick solution grounding with
embeddings and Vector search
what is grounding what are embedding and
Vector search
in this video we will learn these
crucial Concepts to build reliable gen
AI services for Enterprise use
but before we dive deeper here is an
example
this demo is available as a public live
demo please open the demo with this QR
code or the URL on the video description
then select stack Overflow and enter any
coding question as a query
so it runs a text search on 8 million
questions posted on stack overflow
for example if you ask how to shuffle
rows in SQL then it instantly shows
stack Overflow questions that have
similar meaning to your question
the following points make this demo
unique first it is llm enabled semantic
search the 8 million stack Overflow
questions and query text are both
interpreted by vertex AI generative AI
models
the model understands the meaning and
intent or semantics of the text and code
Snippets in the question body at
librarian level precision
the demo leverages this ability for
finding highly relevant questions and
goes Far Beyond Simple keyword search in
terms of user experience
second rounded to business facts in this
demo we didn't try having the llm to
memorize the 8 million items with
complex and lengthy prompt engineering
instead we attach the stack Overflow
data set to the model as an external
memory using Vector search and use no
prompt engineering
this means the outputs are all directly
grounded to the business facts not the
artificial output from the llm
so the demo is ready to be served today
as a production service with Mission
critical business responsibility
it does not suffer from the limitation
of llm memory or unexpected behaviors of
llms such as the hallucinations
third scalable and fast the demo gives
you the search results in tens of
milliseconds while retaining the Deep
semantic understanding capability
also the demo is capable of scaling out
to handle thousands of search queries
every second
this is enabled with the combination of
llm embeddings and Google ai's Vector
search technology
there are two key enablers of this
solution
first the embeddings generated with
vertex AI embeddings API
second fast and scalable Vector search
by vertex AI matching engine
let's start by taking a look at these
Technologies
so what is embeddings
with the rise of llms why is it becoming
important for it engineers and itdms to
understand how they work
in traditional it systems most data is
organized as structured or tabular data
using simple keywords labels and
categories and databases and search
engines
in contrast ai-powered Services arrange
data into a simple data structure known
as embeddings
let's see how AI organizes data using
embeddings
once trained with specific content like
text images or any content AI creates a
space called embedding space which is
essentially a map of the content's
meaning
AI can identify the location of each
content on the map that's what embedding
is
let's take an example where text
discusses movies music and actors with a
distribution of 10 2 and 30 respectively
in this case the AI can create an
embedding with three values 0.1 0.02 and
0.3 in three-dimensional space
and AI can put content with similar
meanings closely together in the space
please note that this is simplified
example for the purpose of explanation
in reality embedding space may have
hundreds or thousands of Dimensions that
can represent almost infinite numbers of
Nano categories of the content
according to the machine learning crash
course embedding refers to the process
of mapping high-dimensional raw data
such as images and texts which have
thousands or millions of Dimensions to a
lower dimensional space using deep
learning models
this is done to extract the meaning or
semantics of the data and create a map
of the content's meaning
this is how Google organizes data across
various services like Google search
YouTube play and many others to provide
search results and recommendations with
relevant content
embeddings can also be used to represent
different types of things in businesses
such as products users user activities
conversations music and videos signals
from iot sensors and so on
Ai and embeddings are now playing a
crucial role in creating a new way of
human computer interaction
AI organizes data into embeddings which
represent what the user is looking for
the meaning of contents or many other
things you have in your business
creates a new level of user experience
that is becoming the new standard
now we have learned what is embeddings
next let's see how we can use it with
vertex AI
on May 10 2023 Google Cloud announced
vertex AI embeddings API for text that
is available on vertex AI model Garden
this API is designed to extract
embeddings from texts
it can take text input up to 3072 input
tokens and outputs 768 dimensional text
embeddings
with the embedding API you can apply the
innovation of embeddings combined with
the llm capability to various text
processing tasks such as llm enable
semantic search text embeddings can be
used to represent both the meaning of
texts in the embedding space
texts that have similar meaning to the
user's query intent will be found fast
with Vector search technology
llm enabled text classification llm text
embeddings can be used for text
classification with a deep understanding
of different contexts without any
training or fine tuning
llm enable recommendation the text
embedding can be used for recommendation
systems as a strong feature for training
recommendation models such as two Tower
model resulting in next-gen user
experience with semantic product
recommendation
llm enabled clustering anomaly detection
sentiment analysis and more can be also
handled with the llm level deep
semantics understanding
vertex AI embeddings for text has an
embedding space with 768 dimensions
as explained earlier the space
represents a huge map of a wide variety
of texts in the world organized by their
meanings
with each input text the model can find
a location or embedding in the map
the API can take 3072 input tokens so it
can digest the overall meaning of a long
text and even programming code and
represent it as single embedding
it is like having a librarian
knowledgeable about a wide variety of
Industries reading through millions of
texts carefully and sorting them with
millions of Nano categories that can
classify even slight differences of
subtle nuances
by visualizing the embedding space you
can actually observe how the model sorts
the texts at the librarian level
precision
nomic AI provides a platform called
Atlas for storing visualizing and
interacting with embedding spaces and
they worked with Google for visualizing
the embedding space of the 8 million
stack Overflow questions
you can try exploring around the space
zooming in and out to each data point on
your browser on this page courtesy of
gnomic AI
here are the examples of the librarian
level semantic understanding by
embedding's API with stack Overflow
questions
for example the model thinks the
question does moving the request line to
a header frame require an app change is
similar to the question does an
application developed on HTTP 1X require
modifications to run on http 2.
that is because the model knows both
questions talk about what's the change
required to support the HTTP 2 header
frame
note that this demo didn't require any
training or fine tuning with computer
programming specific data sets
this is the Innovative part of the zero
shot learning capability of the llm
it can be applied to a wide variety of
Industries including Finance Healthcare
retail manufacturing construction media
and more for deep semantic search on the
industry-focused business documents
without spending time and cost for
collecting industry-specific data sets
and training models
the second key enabler of the stack
Overflow demo shown earlier is the
vector search technology
this is another Innovation we are having
in the data science field
the problem is how to find similar
embeddings in the embedding space
since embeddings are vectors this can be
done by calculating the distance or
similarity between vectors
but this isn't easy when you have
millions or billions of embeddings
for example if you have 8 million
embeddings with 768 Dimensions you would
need to repeat the calculation in the
order of 8 million x 768.
this would take a very long time to
finish
actually when we tried this on bigquery
with 1 million embeddings five years ago
it took 20 seconds
so the researchers have been studying a
technique called approximate nearest
neighbor or an for faster search
and uses Vector quantization for
separating the space into multiple
spaces with a tree structure
this is similar to the index in
relational databases for improving the
query performance enabling very fast and
scalable search with billions of
embeddings
with the rise of llms the an is getting
popular quite rapidly known as the
vector search technology
in 2020 Google research published a new
an algorithm called scann
it is considered one of the best an
algorithms in the industry also the most
important foundation for search and
recommendation in major Google services
such as Google search YouTube and many
others
Google Cloud developers can take the
full advantage of Google's Vector search
technology with vertex AI matching
engine
with this fully managed service
developers can just add the embeddings
to its index and issue a search query
with a key embedding for the blazingly
fast Vector search
in the case of the stack Overflow demo
matching engine can find relevant
questions from 8 million embeddings in
tens of milliseconds
with matching engine you don't need to
spend much time and money building your
own Vector search service from scratch
or using open source tools if your goal
is high scalability availability and
maintainability for production systems
by combining the embeddings API and
matching engine you can use the
embeddings to ground llm outputs to real
business data with low latency
for example if an user asks a question
embedding's API can convert it to an
embedding an issue and query on matching
engine to find similar embeddings in its
index
those embeddings represent the actual
business data and the databases
the stack Overflow demo architecture has
two parts first building a matching
engine index with vertex AI workbench
and the stack Overflow data set in
bigquery on the right and second
processing Vector search requests with
Cloud run on the left and matching
engine
in this video we have seen how the
combination of embeddings for text API
and matching engine allows Enterprises
to use gen Ai and llms in a grounded and
reliable way
the fine-grained semantic understanding
capability of the API can bring the
intelligence to information search and
recommendation in a wide variety of
businesses setting a new standard of
user experience in Enterprise it systems
to get started please check out these
resources
the links are available on the video
description
if you're looking for semantic search
solution with less effort for the
integration please also check General
app builder Enterprise search
the product provides an out of the box
document search solution that integrates
keyword search and semantic search as a
fully managed service
thank you so much for watching this